when you're twitch or youtube famous
weird [ __ ] is bound to happen
and these days are nothing but weird for
popular youtuber dream
after a different youtuber admitted to
creating a
fake dream account impersonating him and
sending some pretty screwed up messages
to his
fans now the apology marks the end
of a month-long feud with that same
youtuber initially
denying everything
all right guys if you want to see more
videos like this you got to scroll down
hit that subscribe button and while
you're at it hit that notification bell
we are well on our way to 2 million
subscribers and we need your help to get
there
all right so youtuber john swan or just
swan recently admitted to impersonating
dream
and to sending some pretty [ __ ] up
messages to random people as him
on discord here's how we got to this
point
in one corner you have dream youtube's
breakout star of 2020
who literally went from zero to 100 in
the span of a year and it's easy to see
why
millions of people scarf down his
minecraft content
i just owned him in the other corner you
have swann who got popular as a drama
or commentary youtuber essentially
talking [ __ ] about
other people talking [ __ ] think of
destiny just
way less toxic but never did i think
that my
series on former to catch a predator
host and nbc journalist chris hansen
would result in some of the most
aggressive harassment
that i have ever experienced all right
now for the fight itself and how it got
started so about a year ago swann
interviewed dream for a minecraft
documentary charting the games rise
fall and resurgence here's dream talking
about that
the collaboration was great i had a good
time it worked out really well
the guy seemed like a nice guy you know
i didn't really talk to him or anything
i talked to him only during the
documentary but
that was it seemed pretty nice you know
and then
three months later that's when drama
struck so yeah
three months after that interview swann
allegedly changed his name and photo to
impersonate dream on discord
and then sent some pretty heinous
messages to people
including ones with the n-word one of
the people that allegedly got
messaged was also friends with dream and
when they reached out and told him about
it
at first he couldn't believe it but then
he saw
the screenshots i didn't i didn't know
what to think i was like somebody's
impersonating me what
so i get screenshots of of this
impersonation account
saying i was going to make a sex
minecraft mod and saying the n-word
and saying other things dream then
confronted swan about it swann denied
doing anything
wrong and blamed the situation on a
quote irl
who had briefly taken control of his
account and dream didn't believe
this and i mean first of all what the
[ __ ] is an irl
did swan mean friend and if he did why
is his friend
impersonating a popular youtuber and
spamming people with racist
messages okay fast forward roughly a
year on february 14th
swann tweeted out that dream was a
douchebag alongside a clip of youtuber
moist critical
criticizing him i thought kai didn't
believe he had an ego i was just going
to say because i went on a podcast with
him and he was telling the story about
like he always knew he was going to blow
up and his advice to up-and-comers was
to be
super confident to the point of
arrogance now after that tweet and that
clip gained a bunch of attention
online voice critical put out a video
clarifying his thoughts on the entire
situation
he said that dream actually reached out
and they talked about the clip in
question
he says that they managed to clear the
air and chalk it up to one giant
miscommunication
from there moist discussed what he feels
can be like a warped
and obsessive relationship that fans
often have
with their favorite creators when you
cross that line into unhealthy obsession
where your entire day an entire online
identity
is based around defending and fighting
for someone else's content who is a
total stranger mind you
no matter how big of a fan you are of
dream tommy or any of the big
minecrafters
they don't know you and you don't know
them you just like their content and
your entire happiness
is placed in their hands for you where
you're living vicariously through their
content
you have a problem now from there a
legion of dream fans went after swan
online which to be honest isn't that
surprising but apparently it was
surprising to him because he tweeted
this out well
thank you to all the stands that have
interacted with my tweets today
this has reinforced everything i thought
about stanz and stan culture
dream video coming out on cordwitz
channel soon that tweet ended up as a
reddit post
and while dream did comment on it the
post went largely unnoticed
dream called out swann for that fake
dream heinous messages situation that we
just talked about
now here's where a lot of people think
swan
[ __ ] up he tweeted out a photo of
dream's reddit response and accused
dream of trying to smear him
and destroy his credibility but then
people pointed out that swan probably
wouldn't have gotten caught
if he didn't tweet out about dream's
largely ignored reddit response
like people started paying attention to
this situation
because swann tried to dunk on dream
from there dream jumped on stream to
talk about the entire situation and
you've already heard some of that in
past clips
context i was replying this on a reddit
with 4 000
users that was a criticism subreddit for
me
in a comment that had 21 likes when he
posted this thread with 3
500 anyway a week later on february 24th
swann dropped an 18-page google doc
basically
responding to everything dream said on
stream now the doc
and swan's twitter have both since been
deleted
so i haven't been able to find and read
that document but here is beau black's
talking about it and reading the first
paragraph
before it was taken down for those of
you who are reading you are probably
already aware of my recent drama with
dream
this situation has blown up far more
than i ever thought and i plan for this
to be the final thing i say on it i take
these allegations seriously but to
address everything completely i need to
go into great detail hence the length of
this document
however this isn't a document to trash
on dream or expose him without proper
context
i can understand why he believed what he
did and i don't blame him for anything
this is simply to give my side for the
story but then on february 27th
nicholas de oro and auggie who were both
friendly with swan
tweeted out that they had been shown
proof that swann lied to them
about this entire situation shortly
after that and the jig
was up swann admitted to everything
impersonating dream
and sending those racist messages and
unsurprisingly
people flipped out here's the first
couple of paragraphs from his apology
that he posted to twitter quote hello
everyone
as a commentator my credibility is
important to me unfortunately i have let
you all down
there is no excuse for what i did and i
take full responsibility
i wish i could have made a video but i'm
currently traveling and not in the
position to do
so i was messing around on discord about
a year back with a friend of mine
i had 6k subs and i thought nothing of
it
this somehow got back to dream and i
didn't expect it to i panicked
i told a lie and i thought it would
never get brought up again
i was wrong end quote now in the
aftermath
people were quick to point out that if
he did do everything he was accused of
swann's entire google doc response was a
lie
and of course dream chimed in with a
long
ass threat he said that he reached out
to swan privately after he was given new
evidence that swann was lying
but dream says swan continued to deny
everything
dream said that he's disappointed in
both swan and the commentary youtube
channels
that accused him of quote going after a
smaller creator end quote
he ended his thread by asking everyone
not to attack people on his behalf
and stated that he's just finished with
this entire situation
now this is not the first batch of drama
that dream has cooked up in the last few
months
at the late end of 2020 dream found
himself accused of
cheating by a minecraft speedrunning
moderator that situation had
multiple long ass google docs stupid
amounts of statistics
and at one point an astrophysicist got
involved
it was a nightmare and of course we
covered it at the time
he was also accused of cheating by
multiple people he got
doxxed after doing a weird neck reveal
and
he hired a harvard trained
astrophysicist to write his defense
paper against those cheating allegations
and apparently it's full of holes so who
knows
for now things seem to have quieted down
but as dream has
shown us the extremely online life of a
famous youtuber
is bound to drop more drama in our lap
at some point soon oh it's me [ __ ]
talking about chips dill pickle chips
are the best
and yesterday i picked up a bag of those
mini crisps yeah the [ __ ] dill pickle
the salt and vinegar the the whole line
of those things
are wonderful hey devon one thing i did
want to ask you
i've been uh talking to some people in
the comments
and uh some people have been enjoying my
sensor sounds in the end boards yeah you
have any idea where that stuff is from
i have no idea what the [ __ ] the sensor
noises are i'm just like ah
okay like whatever colton's going with
is fine with me you know